Regression. Final answer. Yes.
Hello world it Saroj and everyone in
the entire world needs to understand how
regression works.
It's a data science technique that can
quickly give us superpowers of insight
from a massive,
sometimes unintelligible dataset.
Using regression,
we can predict the optimal way to allocate
funds in our organization to increase
sales,
predict demand for a product,
understand the effects of
certain treatments on a patient.
Understand why certain factors contribute
to poverty or economic prosperity.
I could literally go on for hours.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
Whether it's in business research or
even lifestyle design regression can give
us the answers we need from data to
improve our lives and the lives of others.
Now, there are a lot of different
types of regression models in the wild,
including logistic and
stepwise and elastic net.
It can be overwhelming to
try and understand all of
them from a single video.
So we're going to focus on just a few
of the most important ones for our
problem.
We'll play the role of a newly hired
data analysts at a corporation called
engine using a Dataset of our
marketing expenses and ticket sales.
For our newly opened Jurassic Park.
We'll use a regression model to predict
how to optimally increase ticket sales
next month.
Data of finds a way identifying whether
or not the correlation between two or
more variables represent a causal
relationship is rarely easy using human
intuition alone, but if we could
figure that out in a mathematical way,
it would be so much easier to make
business decisions quickly so we can spend
the rest of our time playing Fortnite
to help answer these types of questions.
Data scientists use regression models.
Regressions are used to quantify the
strength of the relationship between one
variable and other variables that
are thought to explain it these days.
Running hundreds of thousands of
regressions has become extremely simple.
In fact, we don't even need to
know how to code. That's right.
Microsoft formerly run
by Youtube sensation.
Bill Gates has built regression
functionality into its
XL product and almost all
of the major tech companies have some
form of drag and drop interface that lets
us immediately apply regression
analysis to a Dataset we upload.
But using a programming language like
python can help us intuitively understand
the mathematics that's happening behind
the scenes and if we understand the
mathematics,
it'll help us build an intuition around
when to use which model for whatever
task we have. So let's start with
the first type of regression,
the simple linear regression.
This is a model that can show the
relationship between two variables.
More specifically,
it shows how the variation
in the dependent variables
can be captured I a change
in the independent variable
in a business context.
The dependent variables can also be called
the predictor for sales of a product
performance,
pricing or risk.
The independent variable also called
the explanatory variable explains the
influence of the dependent variable.
A simple linear regression model is
linear because all the terms in the model
are either a constant value or a
parameter multiplied by an independent
variable.
The core idea is to figure out this model
which when plotted is the line of best
fit for the data.
The best fit line is the one where the
total prediction error of all the data
points are as small as possible.
We can consider the error as the
distance between the data point and the
regression line.
So in our datasets,
after we import pandas
for data manipulation,
num Pi for Matrix math and
Plotly for data visualization,
we can visualize our data first to
see that we're spending money on TV,
radio and newspaper ads each week and the
amount of sales of our product changes
every week as well. Yes, I said newspaper.
Remember this is the 90s let's say we
want to find the relationship between just
TV,
ad money and sales.
Thus we'll want to use a
simple linear regression model.
We can represent this as the
model y equals mx plus B.
The values of both M and B should be
optimal such that the error is as small as
possible when plotted.
There are several different metrics
we can use to compute the error,
so let's use a popular one
called the sum of squared error.
This simply finds the difference between
the actual output and the predicted
output squares. It adds them all up
and that's our final error value.
We then use this error to
update the values for B and
m using a technique called
gradient descent.
Rather than explain how that works,
I'm going to link you to my video aptly
titled Linear regression using gradient
descent in the video description.
When we perform this simple
linear regression will find
that there does seem to
be a relationship between
these two variables.
The more we spend on TV ads, the
higher our sales are. Makes Sense,
but we probably want a more
holistic view of our data,
meaning we want to take into
account the other variables as well,
like the newspaper and radio ads so
we can see how they all affect sales.
If we try to plot just one other feature,
the line we have now becomes a plane.
We're now in three d.
The plane is the function that expresses
why as a function of the other two
variables. This is the genesis of
the multiple linear regression model.
There's now more than one input
variable use to predict the y value.
A model with two input variables is a
longer equation than one expressed with
one.
We can take it a step further and take
into account all three input variables
and create an equation for that
as well. Alas, if we do this,
we are now limited in our capabilities
in terms of what we can visualize in a
graph since we are now dealing
with more than three dimensions,
but that's the wild world of data.
Many data sets have tens if
not thousands of dimensions.
If we again use gradient descent to find
the equation that best fits our data
will receive a model,
we can interpret specifically
the coefficients in the equation.
We can correlate each learned
coefficient with a different feature.
If all the other predictors
are held constant and we
change any of these values,
we can tell what the corresponding
increase in the amount of sales would be,
but which coefficients
are the most significant?
Are they all equally significant?
Does this equation explained
the meaning of life?
Here we turned to the
art of model evaluation.
Notice that all the coefficients
are greater than zero.
That means all the variables
have an impact on the sales. Hmm.
Before we keep evaluating
this model any further,
I have a suspicion we
could use a better model.
My intuition as a digital detective
is that TV ads far outweigh the other
features in terms of significance and
we'll need to prove that are a linear
regression model fits
the data relatively well?
I mean it's not extremely off.
If it was,
we'd want to try to instead
use a nonlinear regression.
A nonlinear regression model is one
where not all the terms in the model are
either a constant value or a parameter
multiplied by an independent variable.
Both linear and nonlinear models
can fit curvature in data,
so that's the main factor to consider,
but since we're doing pretty well so far,
let's not go there right now.
It's also important to note that both
single and multiple regression models can
be either linear or nonlinear.
These four terms are all different
ways of defining regression's.
Before we kick back,
relax and tweet that we've secured funding
for Tesla at four 20 we want to try
to more types of linear regression models,
rich and lasso regressions.
Any linear or multiple regression
model will be sub optimal.
When there is a high colinearity
amongst the feature variables.
Colinearity is a condition in which
some of the feature variables are highly
correlated.
It's sub optimal because colinearity
tends to interfere in determining the
precise effect of each feature variable.
There are a few different ways of
mathematically evaluating this,
but we'll get to model
evaluation techniques later on.
Right now let's just try out ridge
regression to see how it works.
Ridge regression alleviates colinearity
amongst the regression predictor
variables in a model.
Again,
colinearity is we're one of the feature
variables in a multiple regression model
can be linearly predicted from the others
with a substantial degree of accuracy.
If the feature variables
are very much correlated,
the final regression model is
going to cause overfitting,
meaning our model won't be
generalized enough to new data points.
It'd be perfect,
but only for the existing data points.
We don't want that.
So to solve this issue,
Ridge regression as a small squared
bias factor to the variables.
This squared bias factor pulls the feature
variable coefficients away from this
rigidness. I introducing a small
amount of bias into the model.
It reduces the variance,
which means the difference between
predicted data points and the mean of y
immensely.
This trade off of variants and bias will
produce much more useful coefficient
estimates.
When colinearity exists for Ridge
regression will introduce grid search CV.
This is going to allow us to automatically
perform cross validation which will
assess how the results of our model will
generalize to an independent data set
with a range of different parameters.
In order to find the
optimal value of Alpha,
then we can find the best parameter and
the best mean squared error using the
built in attributes.
Thank you. Psychic learn.
Our optimal value of Alpha and MSC are
both slightly better than the ones we got
from art multiple regression model.
This is good,
but I think we can do even
better. Enter Lasso. Regression.
Lasso regression is similar
to ridge regression and
that they both have the same
premise.
In Lasso regression.
We're again adding a bias term to the
regression function so that we can reduce
the negative effects of colinearity
and consequently the model's variants,
but instead of using a squared
bias like ridge regression does,
Lasso regression uses a literal lasso.
Just kidding.
I had to do that at least once.
It instead uses an absolute value bias
and this difference has a huge impact on
the bias variance.
Trade off Lasso overcomes the disadvantage
of Ridge regression by not only
punishing high values of the coefficients
but actually setting them to zero if
they aren't relevant in this way,
we might end up with less
features included in our
model then we started with,
but this can be an advantage
when we implement lasso.
It looks similar to Ridge
and our resulting alpha and
MSC are the best scores of
any model we've used. Looks like Lasso
is the way to go. Using this model,
we can give it values for how much we
will spend on different advertising
mediums and it will predict
the amount of sales we'll make,
which lets us much more
efficiently allocate funds
towards the medium we want to
use saving us money and thus
increasing our revenue. Luckily,
there are only three points
to remember from this video.
A regression model is simple if it
has only one input and one output,
but it's multiple if it has
multiple inputs and one output.
A regression model is linear when all
the terms in the model are either a
constant value or a parameter multiplied
by an independent variable else.
It's nonlinear. Lastly, if a
data set has a high colinearity,
meaning the inputs are highly correlated,
we can use either ridge or lasso
regression to help ensure more accurate
estimates of the regression coefficients.
What do you want to use a
regression model to do next?
Let me know in the comments section and
please subscribe for more technology
videos. For now, I've got to find
a lasso, so thanks for watching.